présente dans 28 pays l'entreprise
wienerberger est l'un des principaux
fournisseurs de matériaux de
construction en autriche dans cette
usine sont fabriqués des briques un
processus qui nécessite de chauffer ce
gigantesque fourre à plus de 900 degrés
impossible sans gaz un arrêt des
importations aurait donc des
conséquences immédiates s'il ya des
arrêts substantielle de la livraison du
gaz russe en europe du centre est
notamment en autriche on sera bien
obligé d'arrêter nos fours
progressivement et ça dépend bien
entendu pour quelle durée mais pour
cette durée on doit mettre nos employés
au chômage technique et on sera donc à
l'arrêt qui aura aussi des combettes des
conséquences assez graves pour
l'économie et surtout le bâtiment en
entrevue si l'autriche soutient les
sanctions européennes contre la russie
elle s'oppose fermement à tout embargo
sur le gaz qui permet de chauffer 900
mille foyers dans ce pays de 9 millions
d'habitants
face à cette dépendance le gouvernement
a présenté un plan pour se passer
totalement du gaz russe d'ici 2027
nous savons désormais à quel point il
est important de sortir du gaz russe
aussi vite que possible pour cela il
faut d'abord réduire notre consommation
augmenter la production de gaz
renouvelables en autriche
c'est à dire l'hydrogène vert et le
biométhane
et enfin nous devons diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement et nous
fournir en gaz auprès d'autres pays
comme la norvège ou le qatar
pour penser une ville sans gaz le
gouvernement peut s'inspirer de
plusieurs projets innovants comme ce
quartier de vienne ici 160 habitations
sont chauffés grâce à des pompes à
chaleur activé par l'électricité
excédentaire produite par des éoliennes
l'énergie stockée dans le toit du
bâtiment une solution d'avenir veut
croire norbert gaillard
avec ce système nous pouvons construire
des quartiers entiers mais le grand défi
qui se pose à nous est aussi de
décarbonés les logements existants en
sortant du gaz et des réseaux de
chauffage urbain
là aussi ce système sous des formes
adaptées offre une possibilité d'y
parvenir pour les siens
pour accentuer cette transition les
verts veulent interdire dès l'année
prochaine la construction de chauffage
au gaz dans les nouvelles habitations